what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder a lot of new the
Marvels news today if you are excited
for this movie I hope it makes you more
excited and if you're not I hope it gets
you a little excited as we have a new
look an exclusive look that was provided
for the marbles and the new look looks
really good it also looks like we know
the exact date and time that the new the
Marvels trailer is going to be coming
out this is going to be the full second
official trailer that should give us a
lot more info on what exactly the movie
is about we also have a toy League that
we want to talk about because it reveals
a cool little detail about the movie a
little fun fact about a really cool
character that most people love now like
I mentioned we do have a new look at the
Marvels thanks to Entertainment Weekly
and as you can see right here here is
Kamala Khan Captain Marvel and Monica
Rambo and as you can see their suits
actually look pretty awesome now Captain
Marvel suit is pretty different than
what we've seen before with her it looks
good though it looks a little bit more
casual not as flashy definitely not as
bright but I kind of like that about it
however we know that this isn't really
going to be her final combat suit this
kind of looks like more casual suit like
a leisure suit because in this other
photo that we get from Entertainment
Weekly we see her new suit and it looks
really good it's really smooth it's
really slick but it maintains pretty
much the same look that she had before
simply enhanced of course the overall
design has changed a little bit but I
think it looks really good but go ahead
and let us know what you think about
this suit in the comments down below and
we'll probably see her wear both of the
suits in the new trailer that we should
be getting Friday morning and when I say
the morning I literally mean the morning
we're talking 12 a.m Friday so late at
night on Thursday technically Friday
morning according to Insider Daniel rpk
who has a great track record with
trailer release dates he states that it
is coming Friday at 12 a.m so that is
just not even a couple of days away he
did state that it could move but as of
right now that is what he's heard also
at the same time the Twitter Insider
account at cryptic 4K qual has released
some photos from the trailer that is
supposed to be coming out Friday further
backing up this claim that we are indeed
getting it Friday or very very soon if
it is not Friday at midnight so for
those waiting for that trailer looks
like you don't have to wait much longer
Thursday night slash Friday morning if
not long after but going back to these
photos and the new look that
Entertainment Weekly gave us we also get
a new look at Miss Marvel's new suit
Kamala Khan's new suit and knowing
Kamala Khan she's going to be ecstatic
about this new suit upgrade we also see
that Monica Rambo now has a superhero
suit and she is supposed to take on the
mantle of photon the character that she
is in the comics and if you look at this
suit it is extremely comic accurate that
is something that Marvel Studios has
treated us to in Phase 4 and Phase 5 so
far comic accurate suits and I gotta say
it looks pretty dang great we also have
a suit of her in action using some of
her powers that she got in one division
it looks great in the photos let's hope
the effects in the movie are just as
good we have a new look at that new suit
for Captain Marvel like I mentioned
before and we have a look at Nick Fury
now right now we are about to get the
finale of secret invasion next week it's
looking like Sam Jackson's Nick Fury is
going to have a considerable role in the
Marvels he is in the first trailer that
we got for the Marvels but some people
were worried and were speculating that
Nick Fury might actually die in secret
Invasion and the footage that we see of
him in the trailers for the Marvels is a
flashback or perhaps that is before the
events of secret Invasion and then the
film jumps forward in time at some point
I don't think that's the case I
definitely think he survived secret
Invasion and is back to the old Nick
Fury and goes back up to saber and
starts to get really involved with
superheroes again and then we have one
of goose who is going to be back for the
Marvel switches really Captain Marvel 2.
Captain Marvel and friends but that toy
League that I mentioned was actually
about goose and what it shows us is that
goose has kids as you can see in these
Funko Pop releases is we have a pop of
goose and we also have a pop of pin who
is seemingly Goose's romantic partner
and as you can see in both of these
photos both of them have kids Goose
actually has three on him and pin as one
so we're gonna see a little flirkin
family that goose has in the Marvels
which is going to be fun and cute to see
Goose had a considerable part in the
First Captain Marvel film so we can
assume that he'll probably have a good
decent considerable part in this film as
well
foreign
now for the last photo we have a picture
of Dar Ben who was rumored to be the
daughter of Ronan the Accuser and if you
can take a look at this photo it
actually looks like she has a very
similar Hammer to the one that Ronan the
Accuser had and if you take a look at
her left wrist she is wearing a bangle
one of the same ones that Kamala Khan
has if you remember from Miss Marvel it
was revealed that there were two Bengals
now they never showed us what happened
to the other Bengal all we knew is that
they only found one Kamala Khan ended up
with that Bengal becoming Miss Marvel
and now we see that darbin has the other
and she probably will know a little bit
more about how to control the Bengals
Powers than Kamala Khan does since
Kamala Khan kind of just got the Bengal
and isn't that experienced yet as a
superhero while on the other hand darbin
is supposed to be a Cree General she is
an accuser much like Ronan the Accuser
for the cree Empire and in the comics
she or he because it's a male character
in the comics they gender swap this for
the movie goes on to become the emperor
of the cree Empire by using an Android
of the Silver Surfer this movie is
supposed to be a pretty big movie and
apparently there are going to be some
kind of cool spoilers in this film now
nothing is confirmed at the moment we
only have rumors but the rumors are
exciting one rumor in particular is that
Nova could be introduced in this film
which does kind of make sense this is
going to be a cosmic film they're going
to be exploring the Galaxy possibly
galaxies trying to figure out what is
going on between the three of them why
each time they use their powers they
swap places and thanks to the first
trailer that we saw we do know that
they're going to be going to different
worlds and talking to different people
perhaps xandar since the events of
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game has been somewhat rebuilt and
perhaps Nova is there with the Nova core
again right now this is only just a
rumor but it actually does make sense
for it to happen and we know that Disney
was at least before planning to do a
Disney plus special presentation or Nova
to introduce him to the MCU you however
since Marvel Studios president Kevin
feige and Disney CEO Bob Iger recently
came out and said they are going to be
cutting back on Disney plus projects who
knows if that is still going to be in
the works perhaps the main Nova debut
could be and the Marvels another plot
point that we've heard about is that
they're going to visit a planet in which
Captain Marvel's husband is at now
apparently Captain Marvel at the time
did not actually know that she was
getting married we don't know 100 what
actually happens but it's something
along the lines of from what we've heard
of her being confused about the ceremony
that she was taking part in whether that
was her not knowing the language that
was being spoken or perhaps there was
just some sort of a miscommunication
what we do know according to this report
is that she ends up getting married and
ends up kind of staying in the marriage
because her husband ends up becoming
somewhat of a friend to her and it's
almost sort of a diplomatic relationship
hopefully we get to find out more about
this in the upcoming trailer so a lot to
look forward to with the Marvels it
looks like the trailer is going to be
dropping Friday and we're going to get a
lot more info on what the actual story
is going to be so be sure to tune in
Friday for our breakdown of the full
trailer if it does indeed come out but
it's looking like it is and don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
recent videos also if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 or some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month if you'd like to
further support the channel you can
check us out on patreon you can also
check out our website and join our
Discord server and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof